wir stehen vor einer der
außergewöhnlichsten präsidentenwahlen in
den vereinigten staaten donald trump
gegen joe biden und ein großer teil des
streits dreht sich um das phänomen der
briefwahl wegen der korona pandemie
wollen wahrscheinlich mindestens doppelt
so viele wähler wie bisher per briefwahl
abstimmen
man sollte meinen briefwahl das kann für
ein land wie die vereinigten staaten
doch kein problem sein
nach das gucken wir uns mal genauer die
sache mit der briefwahl ist so vertrackt
weil sich probleme auf ganz
verschiedenen ebenen da vermischen
man kann ein paar sachen falsch machen
bei der briefwahl und die leute sind
unerfahren weil ganz viele amerikaner
das noch nicht gemacht haben und auch in
den wahllokalen es noch nicht so normal
ist das ganz ganz viele briefwahlstimmen
ausgezählt werden müssen
außerdem muss der transport
funktionieren es müssen rechtzeitig die
wahlzettel bei den wählern ankommen und
ganz pünktlich die ausgefüllten
wahlzettel wieder beim wahlleiter
ankommen
hinzu kommt dass es einfach viel
aufwendiger ist und deshalb länger
dauert briefwahl stimmen auszuzählen
das alles zusammen wäre natürlich mit
ein bisschen guten willen zu lösen es
ist nun mal eine pandemie und es ist
präsidentenwahl das könnte man
hinbekommen
donald trump aber wird nicht müde die
briefwahl zu verteufeln
für ihn ist sie ein sperrangelweit das
einfallstor für wahlmanipulationen in
der demokraten
wir wollen uns jetzt noch mal genauer
anschauen warum trump das sagt ob das
alles völlig aus der luft gegriffen ist
und vor allem wozu das alles führen
könnte es ist ja nicht so als ob
briefwahl für amerika was ganz neues
wäre das hat schon im bürgerkrieg
funktioniert als die wahlzettel mit
postkutschen an die front gebracht
werden mussten
trotzdem gibt es dieses jahr einige
probleme und dass es so unübersichtlich
ist liegt auch daran dass es nicht ein
wahlrecht gibt für die präsidentenwahl
sondern dass die wahl in jedem der 50
bundesstaaten nach eigenen gesetzen
abgehalten wird
vielleicht gucken wir mal auf die karte
denn es gibt ganz verschiedene regeln
wir starten im westen und hawaii haben
sich schon vor kurve
entschieden brief bald zur regel zu
machen dort bekommt jeder registrierte
wähler unaufgefordert einen wahlzettel
zugeschickt wegen der korona pandemie
haben sich in diesem jahr vier weitere
staaten darunter der
bevölkerungsreichste staat kalifornien
und auch die hauptstadt washington dazu
entschieden dieses verfahren zu
übernehmen
andere staaten wollten nicht ganz so
weit gehen sie senden aber allen
registrierten wählern formulare für die
beantragung von briefmarken man sich
selbst darum kümmern ein antragsformular
zu bekommen kann dann aber als grund
angeben dass man wegen corona briefwahl
machen möchte und dann gibt es
schließlich noch fünf staaten die korona
nicht als grund für die briefwahl
akzeptieren dass in staaten in denen
republikaner das sagen haben
lediglich in texas dürfen menschen die
65 jahre oder älter sind die pandemie
als grund angeben alle anderen brauchen
eine andere begründung wie man zum
beispiel im bundesstaat michigan so ein
wahlzettel bekommt das haben wir eine
wahl vorsteherin dort gefragt
wir haben schon gesagt dieses mal
dürften es mindestens doppelt so viele
briefwähler seien wie beim letzten mal
man rechnet mit 40 prozent aller wähler
und das könnte auch ein richtig großes
problem für die amerikanische post sein
denn die hat schon ziemlich viele
probleme geldprobleme und hat deshalb
viele brief sortieranlagen in letzter
zeit ausgemustert
eine der großen fragen ist ob die post
überhaupt in der lage ist so viele
stimmzettel rechtzeitig zuzustellen
viele demokraten argwöhnen dass die post
vielleicht das gar nicht versucht denn
der chef der post der post master
general ist ein alter unterstützer von
donald trump er hat aber hoch und heilig
versprochen dass die post alles tun
werde um die wahlzettel rechtzeitig zu
stellen
doch das vertrauen vieler amerikaner in
die post ist dahin und deshalb möchten
viele lieber ihren wahlzettel direkt in
eine urne werfen und das geht auch in
vielen staaten aber nicht für alle
gleich leicht zum beispiel in texas
da hat der republikanische gouverneur
entschieden dass es in jedem landkreis
genau eine solche dropbox geben darf
also eine ohne in die man direkt seinen
ausgefüllten briefwahl wird in jedem
county eine dass es nicht wirklich
gerecht denn in harris county um die
großstadt houston leben ungefähr
viereinhalb millionen menschen auf einer
fläche von fast zweimal dem saarland in
loving county neben nur 134 leute in
beiden counties gibt es genau eine
dropbox für wahlzettel
das regt die demokraten auf den houston
ist eine hochburg der demokraten aber
vor gericht konnten sie sich auch an
dieser stelle nicht durchsetzen dass es
solche gerichtsverfahren um das
wahlrecht gibt es überhaupt nichts neues
in amerika denn es ist schon lange so
dass republikaner immer wieder versuchen
das wahlrecht so zu ändern dass es etwas
schwerer wird zu wählen denn je leichter
ist ist zu wählen desto besser für die
demokraten denn dann machen
erfahrungsgemäß mehr neue wähler mit
junge menschen neubürger angehörige von
minderheiten
das sind alles leute die normalerweise
die demokraten wählen dass es sich lohnt
die wahlbeteiligung klein zu halten ist
also keine idee von donald trump das
machen die republikaner schon lange neu
an donald trump ist dass er es offen
zugibt
deshalb ist die briefwahl für trump ein
rotes tuch
seit monaten regt er sich auf allen
kanälen darüber auf warum tut er das zum
einen weil er davon ausgehen kann dass
mehr demokraten als republikaner die
briefwahl nutzen das heißt wenn er dafür
sorgen kann dass viele briefwahlstimmen
nicht gezählt werden steigt in der folge
seinen anteil der stimmen
zweitens ist aber auch einfach die
briefwahl jetzt das neue dieses jahr in
allen möglichen staaten wurden ganz
schnell die gesetze geändert und das
macht es trump möglich zu argumentieren
es gibt wahlbetrug und das ist einfach
sein vorwand aus angst die wahl zu
verlieren sagen zu können
diese wahl gilt nicht das ergebnis ist
falsch und das ist der plan von donald
trump er will eine armee von
wahlbeobachtern aufstellen treuen
trappisten die in den wahllokalen gucken
sollen ob es vielleicht irgendwo eine
unstimmigkeit gibt die man ausnutzen
könnte dann gibt es eine zweite armee
von anwälten die dann vor gericht sieht
um diese stimmen anzufechten
hören wir mal rein wie don trump junior
der sohn des präsidenten versucht hat
diese armee aufzubauen
trumps dauerfeuer gegen die briefwahl
fruchtet bei seinen anhängern
trotz corona haben zuletzt in einer
umfrage nur ein viertel der republikaner
wähler gesagt dass sie die briefwahl
nutzen möchten
bei den demokraten sind es mehr als die
hälfte und das könnte zu einem kuriosen
phänomen führen denn zuerst werden am
wahlabend die stimmen ausgezählt die im
wahllokal abgegeben werden das könnte so
eine art ein sieg für donald trump
ergeben heisst man guckt auf die karte
und immer mehr staaten leuchten in rot
der republikaner weil es so aussieht als
wäre trank dort in führung in dem moment
könnte trump anfangen seinen sieg zu
feiern
und wenn dann langsam die briefwahl
stimmen gezählt werden und sich die
karte von roth der republik
langsam aber sicher in richtung blau der
demokraten färbt ruf trump schiebung
fälschung
ihr habt doch gesehen ich habe schon
gewonnen und dann haben die demokraten
noch irgendwelche säcke voller stimmen
dahin gebracht um die wahl noch zu
drehen das scheint sein plan zu sein
1000 sie wollte gerne in der kommenden
em location in der logischen citroën die
ganzen manipulationsvorwürfe von donald
trump lenken von dem eigentlichen
problem ab was sich ergeben kann wenn
plötzlich doppelt so viele amerikaner
briefwahl benutzen und zwar ist dass die
gefahr dass ganz viele wahlzettel
ungültig sind weil fehler gemacht werden
und da gibt es viel was man falsch
machen kann vielleicht hat man vergessen
ein kreuzchen zu setzen auf dem formular
vielleicht hat man vergessen den
wahlzettel so in das innere kuvert zu
tun dass die wahlhelfer beim öffnen des
äußeren kuverts nicht sehen können wenn
man gewählt hat vielleicht ist die
unterschrift nicht mehr genau so wie sie
30 jahre vorher war als man sich ins
wähler register eingetragen hat oder
vielleicht schreibt man seinen
doppelnamen jetzt mit bindestrich und
auf der wählerliste steht man ohne
bindestrich
all das sind dinge die wenn man streng
nach gesetz geht dazu führen können dass
der stimmzettel als nicht gültig
anerkannt wird genauso wie es passieren
kann dass der stimmzettel zu spät kommt
weil die post zu langsam war
das könnte dazu führen dass ganz viele
amerikaner um ihre möglichkeit gebracht
werden das wahlergebnis zu beeinflussen
es hat aber nichts und gar nichts mit
großen betrug zu tun sondern das sind
pannen die vorkommen können
und so hat es fast nichts mit der
realität zu tun wenn jetzt auf facebook
und anderswo trump fans einander davor
warnen dass viele tote viele illegale
einwanderer oder sogar haustiere jetzt
stimmen abgeben könnten
es gibt vielleicht für all das mal
irgendwo einen fall in der
amerikanischen geschichte wo dass
versucht wurde
aber das sind wirklich wenige
einzelfälle die nicht ins gewicht fallen
und die aufgeflogen sind das gebot der
stunde lautet also auf
was man auf jeden fall sagen kann es
wird vielmehr briefwahl stimmen
auszuzählen geben als je zuvor und das
wird relevant wenn es tatsächlich wieder
knapp wird wie es 2016 war die
niederlage von hillary clinton hing
damals daran dass ihr in drei staaten
pennsylvania michigan und wisconsin
insgesamt nur 80.000 stimmen fehlten
wenn es in diesen drei staaten wieder so
knapp wird dann könnte das briefwahl
thema dort alles entscheiden
in diesen staaten ist es den wahlhelfern
verboten die briefwahlstimmen schon dann
vorzubereiten wenn sie sie bekommen in
michigan darf das zehn stunden vor
öffnung der wahllokale in pennsylvania
und wisconsin erst am wahltag selbst
geschehen die wahlleiter haben aber gar
nicht genug personal um in so kurzer
zeit so viele umschläge zu öffnen
unterschriften zu vergleichen und
stimmzettel einzuscannen
deshalb könnte gerade dort
wahrscheinlich szenario eintreten wozu
das dann führt es nicht zu sagen es
könnte also passieren dass in den tagen
und wochen nach der wahl ganz viele
verschiedene gerichte in diesen drei
staaten über anfechtungen entscheiden
müssen
und wer weiß im jahr 2000 ist schon
einmal eine amerikanische
präsidentenwahl am ende vor dem supreme
court in washington gelandet und dort
hat donald trump dafür gesorgt dass er
eine satte mehrheit hat unter den
richtern
das muss nicht alles so kommen aber
donald trump hat schon mehrmals gesagt
dass er das wahlergebnis nur unter einer
bedingung anerkennen wird
wenn er der sieger